[Ambient tones]
- [Deni Avdija:] When I was 17 and I came to play a game,
I was nervous sometimes.
Playing against those fans.
[Cheering]
Everybody wants you to score.
- Yalla Maccabi!
- [Avdija:] Coach is looking at you.
It's not really comfortable situation for a guy my age.
But slowly you break through.
♪♪♪
My name is Deni Avdija. I am 18 years old.
I live in Herzliya and play basketball for Maccabi Tel Aviv.
Maccabi's the best club in Israel, best academy, for you to grow up as a player,
so my family thought that it's the best place for me to go.
I play with really experienced guys that challenge me
and inspire me to keep working.
I try to play my best, to help the team win.
The teammates likes me cuz I'm bringing
the child's spirit into the team.
- [Sandy Cohen:] Yeah, Deni is definitely the childish one around here.
You know, he just kinda has that little
brother thing, so, it's nice.
- I mean, I like to laugh a lot, to smile, to, to have fun.
Maybe I'll do some stupid stuff sometimes, you know?
My goal is to maximize my potential.
Veljko really pushes me to be the best player I can. And you need
somebody that can motivate you and show you you are a good player.
- Establish first contact. That is the most important thing.
You must establish first contact. That's the domination.
And, uh, you have all the tools—to establish the first contact.
♪♪♪
- [Avdija:] I think that I'll need a little bit time
to learn my body and how to play in this level.
So, you know, every player got his own pace.
And he needs to be patient and keep working hard.
That's how I think about it. We'll see where I end up.
- [John DiBartolomeo:] You forget, I mean, Deni—
you see his highlights. You know, he's a top-five pick.
Uh, but at the end of the day, you have
to remember he's an 18-year-old kid
who's getting ready to leave home for the first time.
You know, he has the, the same worries that, uh, kids have.
And he knows it'll be an adjustment.
But, you know, once he gets on the court, he kinda turns it on.
And he becomes all that potential that we see he can be.
♪♪♪
- [Avdija:] Started playing when I was...seventh grade?
I missed a lot of things. Maybe I didn't have the
normal childhood. But it was all worth it, you know?
I'm playing basketball—the game I love. And, and I can take care of my family.
Really, it's the biggest blessing a guy can get.
♪♪♪